this was the moment a relatively calm
morning in the city of danipro
it turned into a rude reminder of the
horrors of War
the government said energy
infrastructure including gas storage
facilities were once again struck but as
ever civilians in residential districts
in dinipro and Odessa became collateral
damage
thank God two Wars saved us we were left
with no windows no glass left intact
there is a huge mess in the apartment
foreign
there were overnight attacks too this
the aftermath of missile strikes in the
South Central City of zaparesia where
local officials said there were several
dead
it is the second time the city has been
hit there is nothing else left to do
this is how we are surviving here living
Our Lives
Thursday's attacks saw the efficient use
of Ukrainian air defense systems this
video shows the interception of at least
one incoming missile in the Kiev region
in all Ukraine's military command says
10 missiles and five drones were shot
down preventing Untold additional
destruction in what was the second
Russian aerial bombardment in a week the
sixth since October with emergency
blackouts in place across the country
and the National Grid describing the
situation as critical president
zielinski said 10 million ukrainians
were without power on Thursday afternoon
that's Grim news indeed as the first
Snows of winter have fallen the
temperature plummeting below zero
degrees there was a glimmer of good news
the extension for a further four months
of a deal allowing the export of
Ukrainian grain via its Black Sea ports
I was think we moved to know that in
Istanbul Turkey
Ukraine Russia and the U.N had come to
an agreement for the rollover of the
Black Sea grain initiative allowing for
the Free Expo thoughts of Ukrainian
grants the four Nation deal brokered by
turkey was hailed by President erdogan
as a benefit to the world's food supply
and security Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Kiev